you ready yeah citizens of the reject Nation
I finally have a real reex t-shirt on and I
think he might my name is Terra by the way it
says RR reject of course it's a real reject
t-shirt I'm not going to lie I wasn't 100% sure
about red and white for that tea the services
one you the guinea pig for it and I think it
looks great I bought it and it's fantastic I
think it looks great it's worth every penny
spent listen we're going to watch pixels
we've both had a rough day so we're choosing
comedy you got to get on it you got to make
sure you leave a like you type in there into
the into the dupes a comment you got to leave
a comment but you also got to ring the bell
ring the bell and subscribe patrons patrons
you're not already Patron we call you super
sexy over there you can get down with it get
sexy get on the patreon you can watch exclusive
content and highlights especially with Greg and
John over there they have a bunch of stuff but
then you can also do like a full syn up with the
full copy with us and watch the whole pixels
with us together if you get on patreon okay
I think that's it like what else do I have
to say I don't know Matt's part of hosting
a YouTube a thriving YouTube channel is you
say way more things that the audience wants to
hear never heard of them before
yeah rocking and rolling already
familiar music that's a big part
of Adam seller movies welcome to
the80s it is summer 82 yes called
it open come on hey give me back
my I assume every child is Adam Sandler's
children surrender Chris Columbus made this
movie okay what else has he made don't ask
I was worried once I once you said it I was like
I can't recall any movies great I think you made
Home Alone Peter dink just this shut up how are
you so good at this you've never even played it
before [Music] Destiny do they still have arcade
championships oh good question I don't know you're
l l lamon soft who told you that the government
cuz I'm this close to figuring out the secret
of the Bermuda Triangle oh my God I love this
kid this movie just got great oh waa my hands
are blazing fast and also I will blast and burn
all my competitor's weak ass mood I can't wait
for little people jokes welcome gamer Dan first
annual worldwide I really like that their style
to the credits oh yeah it looks like a video
game with the hope of connecting to and perhaps
providing a message for extraterrestrial life
oh space based on a short film oh that's really
cool that's a like a dream come true to have
a adaptation brought to life that is not Peter
Dinklage no it's not not all little people are
the same yeah I was like but then why why are we
I think it's a young Peter Dinklage actually okay
yeah that's what I was I think it is him but the
age or something but it's the got it either we're
both terrible people or we got well gentlemen how
about we break this tie let's play Donkey Kong
hoot hoot hoot hoot visuals are surprisingly
well done yeah I love the editing of that that's
cool yeah surprisingly cool little Scott Pilgrim
Vibes I love movies that edit with music hell
yeah congratulations on coming in second you
prick is he going to cry Blaster is the World
Champ What are you how dare you is that boy
going to cry after losing in public in front
of all these people the thing he was really
passionate about you're still going to go to MIT
and something that makes you a millionaire and
maybe even marry Olivia Newton John like it's just
it's Donkey Kong man we don't got to cry bu yeah
we do a plus you're married to a woman who hates
you she doesn't hate me she just doesn't get it
you know oh man I don't have the free time to
do stuff together like we did 10 years ago he
always has Kevin James and shitty relationships
in his movies catastrophic catastrophic I got
it sweetheart okay damn great coverage on these
yell at me you're mean the casting for the kids
is 10 out of 10 you got to learn how to read buddy
it's as simple as that I was on three hours sleep
all right nice to see is he the actual president
yeah I guess so that's why it's all thrown out cuz
he's the actual president mean you incredible at
video games back in the day but that's a useless
skill now it's like being a great blacksmith
I love that the president has time to talk
to yeah Mr President if you take away all the
library sir how will the children ever learn to
read that's a terrible friend right there oh
this is like the video game what's you call it
t no no no the gala I forget I forget the names
of all I know what you're talking about yeah I
always play it too this that transition was dope
hello I am a nerd from the nerd Brigade here to
nerd out on all your audio and visual needs
do you have to say that every time you show
up at a house if I want to get paid yes isn't
that kind of demeaning only if someone brings
it up thanks oh so it's like 10 birthdays yeah my
dad cheated on my mom with his 19-year-old Pates
instructor when your son told me that
your husband left you for 19y old I
guess I thought of you were going to be like
one of those hot when we first met in high
school oh just have a fling with him yeah do it
Lady Michelle Michelle what's her name Michelle
Monahan yeah okay I did have it right but then I
was like I might be wrong what the hell are those
oh this is going to be like they're fighting but
fighting against a video game but in real life I
love it I played when I was your age were you
any good just a reminder Tara did not ever see
the trailer for this so she has no idea I don't
I'm probably saying a lot of things that you guys
are like we already knew that no no it's great not
judging but what are you doing in the closet maybe
she's changing I'm mostly crying yeah a little
drinking a little drinking probably equally
crying and drinking something I do often also are
you all right I'm sobbing on the floor my closet
drinking charlot out of his sippy cup so I guess
not that shot with the mirror is a surprisingly
good shot yeah that is that's [Laughter]
awesome want to talk about it no this is
good this is when you take advantage of her in her
vulnerable state that's how you do it guys out of
here wowza wow Whoa man if only these army people
knew about video games it's nice to see a comedy
shot with a sense of style yeah whoa this is
that's cool I love just what happened just
what happened just what just happened just what
happened I love [Laughter] it oh oh my God get
out of out of there get out of there cubed cool
I mean this point I'd be like just take me take
me to Pacman or Mrs Mrs Pac it's not even
spelled correctly also it will end terribly
for him she's 19 but she's probably hot I know
but she knows nothing but when you're having a
midlife crisis that's what counts what's going to
happen when she wanders into a bar and she sees
a normal 25-year-old man and she's like didn't
help us you already married the wrong guy you
got the worst part over with true divorce is Good
married the wrong girl divorce is great maybe it
just means we're going to meet the right person
now this is their meat cute in the closet with
wine uhoh oh no no to no are you trying to
kiss me absolutely not oh offense I don't
think my rebound guy is a 210 lb person that
installs flat screens for a living no offense
that's very offensive uh rude I am not a snob
that's pretty snoby s i was a billionaire and
we were out on my giant yacht in the middle of
the Mediterranean sipping champagne and I went
in to kiss you would you have kissed me back then
yeah I would have kissed the guy yeah me too give
me more of that champagne when can I come on this
yacht again for the record I'm an amazing kisser
all us nerds are cuz we appreciate it more Amen
brother you didn't even brush your teeth this
morning I hate a Tic Tac I will say compared to
other Adam Sandler comedies as of late this one's
great I really love it and I like that there's a
different kind of dynamic with the love interest
versus they just get along he got to the White
House in 15 minutes that's insane reminds me of
the show 24 when they were like yeah I'll make
it to LAX in 10 minutes I'm like those are all
lies we right on through Lieutenant Colonel
Lieutenant Colonel yeah what they just keep
subverting expectations on the female leading
stereotype Colonel Ben Patton you can go right
into the Situation Room Mr berer the president is
waiting for you in the Oval Office somebody's more
important Freddy can you keep the Riff Raff out of
here like how they had to cut in on that because
it obviously wasn't Adam Sandler actually doing
it does that sound familiar to you yeah where
do I know that from you freeze it yeah hold
on this movie is like every slacker nerds
fantasy hanging out with the president you take
your gaming skills to saving the world I love it
preliminary indications are that we were attacked
by G Galaga oh yeah Galaga that's what it's called
G gag sons of [__] then let's blow Gallagher
to Hell who's Gallagher this is the 1982 arcade
version kind of Ziggy zaggy Ziggy zaggy is that
the snobby term design these space bugs after an
old out of print version of a video game does
she really get to talk twice she's not even at
the grown-ups table yeah and she's a woman get
this girl out of here if this gets out to the
press that we're pinning the blame on some old
computer game impu you'll be fine we've seen
it your impeach end okay know is that a naked
butt in the background it might be oh it is
oh it wasn't naked it was just khakis just
jeans I was like what stop it's me it's me
it's l it's l oh at the beginning of the
movie CIA has been tapping my phones ever
since I found out this auder film has
been edited JFK shot first llo it is
you you're the first guest I've had here Walt
Disney that's a shocker wow I think they really
lean into their like sci-fi uh tones in a really
fun Whimsical way actually I think if she was
real things might just play out a little bit
differently you want to know how I know that
in the game if she was real a book written and
illustrated by L soft oh boy oh my God I love it
she just why am I here right now why did you try
to rofy me right thank you for reminding me uhhuh
okay do you remember how there was a tape of the
event in all the games that were played that was
then put in a capsule and shot out into the
universe looking for extraterrestrial life oh
I get it and has sent down real life versions
of of what they saw to attack us they probably
thought that's what Humanity was or what weapons
are we are aace from the planet vula we came to
you in these familiar Earth forms to tell you
we received your vessel this all happened on
National Television you have two lives left losing
both will lead to the total Destruction of your
planet did they actually get Don to is that some
old archive footage we don't know about at least
warn the people of India something could be
coming the whole country thinks I'm a buffoon
right now as it is I can't risk it brener I just
can't and this is how they sold movie pixels in
India
whoa he's going live I think
he's just recording he's going
recording that the most relatable
thing try record going to try recording
I would have tried that is a disturbing
effect actually we Now understand the
entities that attacked this were made
of energy intelligent energy morning Colonel
good morning Michael what cool head Mel the
cubes we recovered in Guam are normally
pretty feisty oh he didn't like it though
I love how Adam Sandler's attitude is always
just so passive and unaffected and the uh uh
slut-seeking missile I'd love to see that do
you have that around here that's great that's
a great call back I so regret trying to kiss
you I would kiss the guy in the yacht a 100
times before I kissed you of course snob oh it
hurt his feelings civilian arcaders who we are
required to listen to for 120 seconds starting
I can't do this I love ran know now I can't do
this I love no matter what genre Brian Cox is
in he is so committed perfect someone forgot
to send us the best of the best oops and instead
dropped off a bunch of incontinent adult diaper
wearing women baby men people what am I looking
at right now are you guys soldiers or the cast a
magic mic what are you doing you do you feel me
s You Beautiful Nubian man you gorgeous specimen
of what God can make form extremely complex Mo
defeats with hand eye coordination unique to a
very specific cognitive Acuity I learned
a lot of big words at the dorm room drug
parties let us teach you a few things in the
little time we have we might help you win this
thing I love how they're the two most qualified
people like yeah ain't no way Ink's catching up to
you I want you to focus mostly on the ships
no distractions just us oh my God his wife
who whoa Big W from 30 Rock yeah Jane k Kowski
the next battle is on at sundown tomorrow 5130
29 latitude 0942 longitude where is that London
in London England everybody believes currently
that I'm from there oh dude you're nailing the
near by there would you like small T I know how
to do cookney pretty well London is more proper
proper it's a lot more [Applause] proper that's
great oh my God see it was a naked butt in the
beginning we he's got he's got he's going to
die Shan Bean dies I don't want to hear another
word out of you walk in weer coat what wiener
coat it's really is just like one of those big
a coat for your wieners yeah okay you said it
was a big okay I get what you were trying to
say I was trying to make a different point
okay about how it's like a big sci-fi movie
of Alien Invasion W came got it I know right
but yeah sure big wiener I just want to touch it
easy with those light cannons that's a cool shot
boom boom boom there's some surprisingly good
shots at this comedy movie yeah just remember
who you're talking to Missy move it colonel
don't worry they're going to work he was kind
that was sweet in case it's Space Invaders I just
thought of something I should tell please return
to the support area we know where to find you
all right now booger off but he's the guy you
need I love all these like quick moving
crane shots it's great it's so pretty
though oh snap wa it's centipede what a great
advertisement exactly what we talked about
right people are like what's centipede got to go
find it now I don't know centipede centipede is
a oh you know Cen yeah know I oh wow that's
why I brought you here cuz I forgot the how
old you are yeah I'm 55 my God will you please
find the pattern and anticipate I don't know
the pattern Sergeant death 12:00 oh wa Dam
oh bye-bye kind scary oh no [__] just got
real the hell kind of be commercial
is there's really great callbacks
in thisal grab the done yourself dude
yeah buddy there we go oh my God this
the most badass he's ever looked [__] y
he's saving the world whoa this movie is
making Adam Sandler look like an action
[Music] hero something he will never
be this is such a nerd fantasy I am eating this
up you mess with the wrong planet from Len to
Jon gr what the hell are you saying I know me
no look at me I look delicious they'll gobble
me up like space dim some oh I can't wait
for the president to get involved come on
you're the Wonder kid you've no authority to
dispense weapons here Mr brener oh my God Mr
President let let the Nerds take over what
was that sir let the Nerds take over let
the Nerds take over I want that on a t-shirt
let the Nerds take over I would wear it every
day yeah baby it's actually a cool concept to
take these arcade games to turn them into like
[Music]
villains that's really dangerous
there's people back there what
would you do after this is all solved
though reconsider a lot of things we
can actually I feel like you would just
get really good at video games you know
a movie is working when you don't even
know what the game is yeah it's like a
basic concept to understand though yeah
these effects are really good they're
surprising that looks awesome 30 years
since I kicked your butt like there's
effects from movies right now that I'm
like they don't look good and this looks
dope wow wa arms yes let's take
it for uh [Laughter] [Music] yeah
that's so dumb and cute how does
she not hear this she's old Gregory
[Applause] perfect shot nice who are you mis
son I'm just a loser who's good at old video
games well thank God for that bring down the
US government you know you're all right priner
you're all right too snobby you're going to nurse
that all night long or when are you going to start
snobby hottie that's what I'd call her she's
really hot m I was the Vodka shot record holder
in my class at West Point that's not vodka that's
a skull that's tequila please accept one of our
Warriors as a trophy of your Victory I'm pretty
sure they're just taking this old footage and
they're doing lip dubbing that is so cool they're
doing duck [Music] hunt the details will be sent
via this signal shortly there just some digital
effects real leading two battles to one I think
you might be right about the lip dubbing be
it buddy there's nobody better than you well
not at every game o Peter Dinklage Peter Dage
where is he know he's R Runner come on now we
don't even know where to find that idiot yes I
can't wait made about 50 million before he was
convicted in sentenced to 20 years in prison he
just such an ultimate badass oh God I love him
get me out of here it's that mean centipede
killer I hope you don't at me with his space
gun sup second place oh in your Sidekick here
this is why I don't think I can have Brena on
my team he's just not really a gamer did he have
a southern draw at the beginning of the movie
yeah no no no hey he hey here come on sit
down okay this like d personally speak to
the parole board and I want a stealth attack
helicopter like they fly over the Super Bowl
at my disp at all times you so I can fly
around if you help us beat these things I
think we can get you out of here and the Martha
Serena sandwich pick one of them we'll set up a
coffee Serena Williams and we are [Music] closed
hello he made the right call Serena's the better
understand but Martha Stewart knows how to
decorate New York City oh forget about it
it's nice to see him let loose solid establishing
shot damn it got a lot of big uh Big Crane shots
in this rookie just tell him what you saw
it was it was awful nice like one of those
monster movies you know but this time the
monster was real and who was this monster
Pac-Man yes Pacman boom that's my jam boom let's
get us some little ghosts you want ghosts she's
got ghosts ghosts oh man dude I totally get
how they were able to fun this movie awesome
cuz it's so awesome so much they're going
to go that's so cool four many generators
for each of the cars ghost we're calling them
xm950 love how they had this prepared in case
that they had Pac-Man why are there four of them
there's only three of us who's our fourth may
I introduce to you professor toru iwatani is
that the inventor ofac creator of Pac-Man oh
[Laughter]
man you speak Japanese no sir what an honor
thanks for all the joy you brought to our
lives even in an accent I made your game my
[__] what is a b a mhm Buckle them in you
all right yeah why L's right you do smell
good good luck yeah don't buckle in any of
the other guys that way I know you really
like me for me all he had to do is become
a big Action Hero gentlemen I'll be sending
Pac-Man's current coordinates to each of your
cars GPS's let's locate and eliminate is
this about to turn into the Fast and the
Furious or The Italian Job have you seen that
oh yeah that's such a great [Applause] movie
that is awesome Pac-Man's a bad guy uh-oh oh
I created him to bring joy to all the people
of the world I brainwashed him oh my God I love
it it's kind gentle it's one you can tell your
troubles to or grab a hamburger with what is
that your Pac-Man it is his Pac-Man this just
some like you'll see Recreation you'll see I
knew it I was like I hope he gets out of the
car and talks to it and it's like you're not
you're not meant for this I would talk to him
yes he's my son no that's a bad idea it's
a great idea I love everything about it he
just listening hello my sweet little boy he's
going to die right like immediately think you
grown I know you're a good boy he's going to
be chomped [Music] oh somebody kill the stupid
be all right losers three on one let's hit it oh
they got rid of the inventor wonder if there was
the actual inventor he is right I assume he is
yeah whoa that was a cool shot yeah they have
a great way of like because it's part of the
world that whatever it comes in contact with
turns into a cube it makes it look more tangible
and real yeah they couldn't have made their cars
faster they're just Mini Coopers they're not that
fast Mini Coopers are known to be so [Music] fast
Neato whoa Eddie how did you do that so fast
cuz I'm the champ lieutenant do it off screen
I mean if it was me I'd be in like a 1967 elor
a Mustang or a Camaro wen't you guys ghosting
it oh way' it Go Peter but doesn't it usually have
three lives yeah they got to do it two more times
I love Pac-Man all right Pac-Man number two just
regenerated four streets away headed Northbound
I would love to get a Pac-Man AR yeah that'd be
cool I would love to not pay you to be here and
use all that [Laughter] [Music] money what you
guys forgot to anticipate he's coming for you
know what he hate the power pellet Pac-Man's
got 10 seconds where he can eat us oh God I
didn't know it was only 10 seconds is whole my
whole life I did not know that only 10 seconds
you just got to survive oh which obviously you
never did oh God don't eat me don't eat me don't
eat me please please don't eat me oh gosh no
oh that's going to be awesome if they show him
just in a cut off car the rest of the time I'm
going to die oh who all right one up let run PP
your legs go baby someone's going to run into him
right now yay how the hell did he get over there
so fast way to go champ there's a dve Busters in
the backr yeah thrilled one more to go in a happy
hour I love that that was probably
intentional oh no what oh no BR
it's on you Peter can swim there
are still three other power pellets
out there so stay alert yo this is
more than just a video game you are
driving on the streets of New York
City I feel like you could have gotten an actual
professional driver instead
of Gamers for this yeah true
six that is some serious backward
driving [Music] eight n whoa it's
going to bump into him 10 perfectly
timed wow you are the most badass guy in
the world wait a minute he was Zohan he can
do action he actually did like Israeli military
training for that movie he did yeah he actually
knows how to [Applause] yeah I don't know
why that just popped in my head right now
brvo yes then he's also a Superstar nerd
Fantom government will chew you up
and spit you out though after this
let me guess Michelle comes down and
she's like I don't know I'm thinking
about the line that she's going to say we
love you Mr President thank you for saving
us I don't know what would be worse them failing
are them actually pulling this off this movie
about to take a completely unnecessary turn I
yes so do you recognize this game for my life
do you know what this game is is this left
for dead no oh that's the only video game I
know and I loved it it's The Last of Us come
on up I feel bad because I was going to wear
a real reject Last of Us shirt today but you got
one on no I don't one of our two he's so cute oh
no sorry oh good again I'm a snob I have mental
problems I'm willing to overlook that for the
evening I like their chemist I I normally feel
like Adam Sandler wies in movies like there's
no chemistry they just cast like hot woman
you're my likable wife agree and she's they
actually have like a build in their development of
their relationship it's like cute pass it's cute
yeah look at him oh my God he's he's he's back
from Hitch he just has to be himself well look
at here Serena they threw me a big party to
thank oh my God they got Serena he actually
got Serena they promised me an island if I
did [Laughter] this wower dang girl excuse
me for a second like that's his new future
family dance I like how everyone's accepting
this alien creature and not going like it's
shouldn't we fear this yeah like it's just it
is what happened brush your teeth you brushed your
teeth yes yes callbacks in this are 10 out of 10
man he's musically trained you know who
he is Olaf right yep does he sing a lot
in that movie I'm not Olaf sings A lotf
has a whole musical number even think
about touching me I'm going to smack you
through the wall I'd have it no other way
should have gone with Martha Stewart then
I'd have a tasty Panini cooked for me or
something you have violated the rules of
warfare dudes violated the rules because
of this you forfeit and your planet is
now ours oh Peter Dinklage cheated what
that's why he was going so fast oh what
the heck are they talking about me that
song yeah oh oh you're in trouble now the
Pac-Man cheat code for super speed you're
a cheater so what I used cheat codes back in
the day to help me dominate he's not a real
master that's how I beat your boy brener
at the world championship oh yeah oh you
son of a [__] oh man I have everything
I have to these bitching shads this ends
now how could it apply to a car though
drop dead Admiral you're done all right
hey guys it's enough listen we tried something
it didn't work what do you think it's going to
be you going to be doggy Kong I really don't
know what about duck hunt oh we just saw the
dog no no now it's personal oh boy uh-oh
this is no good where's Eddie Eddie yeah
crawled into a hole we'll never see him again
oh and the little boy is the only one with the
answers wait a second cubert is from there he
knows all their secrets yeah ask him all the
questions we have a positive can do attitude I'm
kidding we are all going to die I'm just [Music]
sorry oh my God Ready Player
One waa have you seen Ready
Player one yeah great film damn
you Terra could have reacted to
iter whoa wow they're not even naming them
now for me to remember what the names are
just a lot of familiar [Music] imagery Tetris
wa that's a clever way to make tet antagonistic
yeah who is it nobody's better at the oh
[__] the president's here thanks for
being my friend of course buddy I love you I
go kick some ass you know everyone says Adam
Sandler is like the nicest guy everyone says
that yeah like real life I bet you he is some
murfs so
hot what is this game I don't know what that
game is get away from those kids
now uh please paper boy in the
background nice head shot oh my God
she's real the girl of his dreams
damn she does look hot hey girl hey
is that ashle something one of those
hot actresses that's her she's an
actress and she's hot I prayed for
this but apparently you don't feel the
same no dude winner over you're in luck
the boss wants to meet you in person
who is this I don't know I've been
trying you save your planet and destroy
our Warriors put in the coms but if you
lose uhhuh looks like one of those
creepy '90s sci-fi things at least
I can die a happy man knowing that I found true
love recognize
him she's like so subtle in her reaction to
it all wow Josh you lucky guy and I couldn't
even get a handshake from Serena Williams
I had to prove to myself do this without
cheating wait you cheated moving [Laughter]
on perfect love I like this movie way more
than I thought I would yeah it's great it's a
lot of fun what is that noise it is is Donkey
Kong I was going to say oh that's really neat
they set him up for so long that I was like it
would be a real disappointment if they didn't
use it that's awesome the one game you suck at
yeah oh they got a rescue hit
oh that's clever cool oh no
oh no a God I can't pinpoint that
robot game it's really bugging me
Just Let It Go Greg Let It Go many of
them I mean what's that chef from I don't
know what a lot of these are [Music] from
W awesome this is a really cool looking
set yeah looks like they actually built
something and mixed it with visual effect
actually yeah yeah damn that was cool oh
you damn I can't do this there's no pattern
pretend you're the guy and you don't want to
die yeah man I couldn't even beat any plant
any plant's a cheater that's why he was so
good in New York he used cheat codes he
can see it now you know what that means
right you're the best I'm the Donkey Kong
champion of the world Donkey Kong champion
of the world doesn't need patterns button I
found that really funny oh love commitment to
it sincerity of oh my God that was the most
genuine delivery of that line that was so
awesome rock
you please oh help him what no
no
dope this a remix yeah yeah yeah took me a second
to pick up on it this shouldn't be so
cool but it is it's so it's so cool
yeah damn you just needed the confidence
oh this would have been so cool to be born
yet when this movie came out to go to the
popup bar I've been waiting to do this since
[Music] 1982 yeah
wa other than the one Frogger thing Kevin James
really hasn't done much in this movie but no in
terms of like fighting the AL yeah he was just
kind of there my second favorite President you
know Obama's still my man right oh okay
so he this is a fictional movie if Trump
did beo president get ches no more taxes
we did it baby we did it oh [Music] right
I love Peter dig reaction to that he's just
like waa man Brena you are the best in the
world the Donkey
Kong lady Lisa she made an appearance and while
you guys were out you know saving the world you
kind of destroyed his oh that's horrible Jen she's
so underused though oh yeah she literally has had
two lines I guess we get to keep the trophies yeah
but he had a trophy wife can he morph into her
which would have its own weird implications
yeah I feel like what's happening it might
happen that mean they're going to lose cubert
though he loses his friend so she gets get the
[Applause] [Music] wife what about cu no
one else is weirded out by this that was
just cubert thank you I have broken a peace
treaty with the Alien Invaders I think Chris
Columbus directed one of the Harry Potter
movies really yeah I think so nerds are the
greatest kissers prove it I'll be the judge
of that for want get a round of applause
yay is it is it Martha Stewart
is it did they get Martha oh
Serena it's a pleasant surprise oh my God
got that's so funny that's a really funny ending
are they just now leaving ah he's [Music] back
game over yeah my shirt literally or shirt
literally says game over game over one year
later what's going on here did she pop
out of baby for for him oh okay yeah oh
God what is a funny ass ending that's great wow I
like the music in this film I actually always like
the music in Adam Sanders films cuz I'm 65 years
old this was a fun movie it was fun these are some
really inventive credits yes I love it also if you
guys are listening to this remember on Spotify or
on Apple podcast or any podcast make sure that
you rate this episode please we love it and you
now let's get into the review I just rhymed you
did just rhy I felt it you felt it everybody felt
it yeah it was very very impressive thank you now
before we go into this review I did want to say
Tera just another compliment what is it what's
it going to be those people on Apple and Spotify
I probably can't I don't know I think there's a
video on there it's been a while since I've I put
someone else in charge of it PL I hope you're
doing a good job on there is it audio or video
so are there are video now I'm not sure actually
ah but that shirt looks great on you terara I'm
transitioning everyone here at the on the channel
now has shirts I appreciate everyone who bought
one buying that one and uh to everyone in reject
Nation who has bought a shirt thank you so much I
got this r on right now the game over shirt here
it is on screen for y'all I love that one every
shirt that you see from the reject Nation shop we
have personally been involved with with helping
to uh create ourselves then you know we also got
like our space babies of the galaxy shirt which
is another one of our favores I got this America's
ass one which is a homelander but we got a whole
bunch of other te's seriously thank you guys it's
personally my favorite way for people that support
the channel just because I think this is the first
one you're wearing can you attest that it actually
feels we made sure that the fabric that we got is
actually nice shirt that I I want to wear and even
if I wash it it's still going to be it's going
to be even more soft and cuddly because I have a
billion shirts that I do not wear because I hate
they're hard material they're gross like these
are not that they're very comfy really care about
the fabric and uh so yeah guys thank you so much
but Tera please oh you want me to tell you what I
thought about the film I want you to talk about it
darling yeah all right and I really liked it a lot
I thought it was a lot of fun I'm uh I like number
one for me in the script all of the callbacks like
if I were if I was reading this script I would go
the callbacks in this make this movie just like
take it from like an eight to a 10 the callbacks
are hilarious and they're really the the pacing
of this especially comedic wise of course with
the actors because they're comedic actors but
specifically with the editing that does matter
and all of the pacing of the editing was really
spoton when it came to the comedy delivery which
I really really liked um and just an real a very
inventive and fun story like watching video games
and having to fight him is rad um and I you know
like what you were saying about uh Adam Sandler
and like his wives and like sometimes Adam Sandler
films they come off to me like from the beginning
I already know that I might be like taken out of
it or that it'll be too corny and this one I was
like sold on it immediately like from the start
also my last thing and then I'm all let Greg
take it away the kid in the beginning who plays he
played uh Josh Gat character where did that kid go
cuz someone needs to cast him in everything he's
hilarious like I want that kid to be in my short
films that's all I got to say no dude I'm sure you
got more to say I love what you have to say I have
a lot but I also I already talked about the music
solid I I think this movie gets so many points
from me I'm I am by no means an Adam Sandler I
love Adam Sandler and I know that when it comes to
you know review circles especially he is very much
consistently critically panned for a lot other
than his dramas which he's a fantastic dramatic
actor yeah cuz it is strange he demonstrates so
much of his versatility and and uh so much of his
depth in his dramatic roles yeah and then he does
comedies and usually he's just like hanging out
on camera like most of the time sometimes he puts
a little bit more effort than usual but most even
this is a great example like yeah he kind of just
hangs out he just hangs out on camera and and and
to me I can still see those Sometimes they come
across like a lazy film they can come across like
he's just on vacation and they got cameras pointed
but sometimes that's still enjoyable you know yeah
uh what I so this gets a lot more points for me
because I know so many of those other films uh
and this you could really feel the conscientious
effort I feel put in you know so already on that
comparative note it gets a lot more points because
I think directing wise there's a lot of great
effort here there's a lot of cool like symmetry
with the shots the visual effects uh the world of
them is really neat and then on just a standalone
as a comedy movie you know I really don't feel
like we get as many comedy films now we don't you
know it's kind of like a dying film genre yeah it
kind of is and then whenever they come out in the
theaters they tend to flop you don't you don't get
just direct like theatrical comedies anymore yeah
weird I'm now just it's hitting my brain where I
I'm I'm thinking like more recently it's been like
right it went like Barbie Oppenheimer and then
we get like well now it would be Expendables and
these are movies I you are John Wick Expendables
and uh what's the one with uh I need to watch it
equalizer equalizer those are I'm naming movies
that are not comedies I don't know I can't name a
comedy that has come out is it like a Dying Breed
now there was Joy Ride and no hard feelings I saw
no hard feelings so yes they do still exist they
exist but they don't like it's it's uh it's doing
well on Netflix but they don't do well in the
theaters anymore in the theaters anymore it's
been a long time yeah I mean the last time I feel
like I watched a like a comedic film is on Netflix
would be like oh you click it at home right
you're not going to pay exactly they're usually
like streaming and a lot of times they have to be
a little bit more High concept like something a
little bit more akin to this where it's like
like it's like action sci-fi adjacent to the
comedy right so yeah I mean it goes down that path
but I the reason I'm saying saying that is that I
was like it's it was just nice to watch a comedy
again and it was my the little nitpicks are yeah
Jan Kowski or whatever her name is krinski sure
yeah that's John that's John I don't know what
her name is yes I do Kowski monik is lazowski I
think she's Kowski I love him okay then there's
John krinski yeah then he did um quiet place
yes and he was in some other comedy show and
they think I don't know but but you know something
than more than you let on I get what you do you
play the you you weaponize your incompetence I do
that in my relationship you do it on camera I do
it on camera for the people for the public for
all the world to see so but the this other than
like okay yeah any comedy movie is going to have
jokes that are not that funny that it's just how
the territory goes like you're going to not and
sometimes some my find every joke funny sometimes
not funny yeah then and then Jane Kowski was um
disappoint like yeah like why C two lines she's
known for not cast her and you're paying her a
daily rate every time she is there on set acting
and if they take a percentage and that's how
they got these people like they're only on there
for a second when I saw Michelle Monahan's name I
thought she would be utilized the way Jane k yeah
but when I saw Jane kosowski I was like oh comedic
actress this is probably going to be worthwhile
and they did nothing like she's there's not even
anything remotely attempting to be F playing a
wife she's yeah remarkably straightforward count
them there is no more than three lines that come
out of her mouth yeah that was the most surprising
part because she is uh she was the only thing I've
seen her in is 30 Rock and and I thought she was
incredible in that and but everyone else like to
me when you put Adam Sandler in a comedy movie
it's great to have surround him by other like if
he's going to do the whole like he's he's just
kind of enjoying himself on camera cuz whether
he's rich or poor he's going to be the guy in a
t-shirt and shorts you know doesn't matter he's
always going to be like the laid-back guy and to
put him in here surrounded by a movie that has
a good production budget that has uh attention
to detail in the visuals that has an ensemble
around him that's really putting in a a concerted
effort with the like Josh gad's really playing a
character even Kevin James is like doing a hybrid
of you know Kevin James and playing the president
you know he's actually putting in an effort to
play a character and Peter Dinklage of course
and even Michelle Monahan I think this is when
Adam Sandler is utilized best uh when we just
want him to be the relatable Adam Sandler that
we all love to hang out with and I thought the
rest like I like Kevin I liked everyone here and
Josh Gad can be kind of Hit or Miss for me and I
I actually like them a lot too that's what I was
going to say Josh cat is in this the Sci-Fi thing
that used to be on Apple TV like it came out
two years ago I don't even know the name of it
I watched a few epod I've never seen it no it's
maybe it wasn't on Apple it was like it's a you
guys know it they're in space and stuff goes
down they keep them on that spaceship listen
Josh Gad was in it talking about and I was like
I don't like Josh Gad this I it got me off of him
because I don't remember him from a lot of films
or TV shows before I just was like oh yeah that's
Josh Gad and oh crap he's the voice of Olaf and I
was like he's fine but I I didn't really like him
and in this movie I'm like oh I get the Josh Gad
thing now meaning if I had seen this first I'd be
like I understand why he is a huge fan base yeah
because he is very funny and I really liked him
in this movie he was this is that kind of clich
that the mom's basement nerd character is has been
done to death yeah but you know implementing
it with a conspiracy theorist and I thought
he I thought he actually did I'm trying to put
my finger on it of what he did different than
what you normally see like yeah he still got that
disheveled look but it's not extreme in the way it
is he seem he actually seems smart and competent
he's not playing it like Kookie there's actually
like a Dr about it yeah I think it feels just more
grounded in like internally who he is but kind of
like uh kind of like sometimes when you see Jack
Black and you're like there there's sometimes when
he's like more ground and still Jack Black but
then other times you're like he's going full on
like 120% Jack Black it's that vibe I like I like
it when he plays a little closer to home I like
that with most actors but um yeah that's that is
what it felt like in this movie possibly for him
because I believe what you're saying is the Sci-Fi
thing I'm thinking of I still can't remember the
name he he does play I think like a zany kind
of character and I yeah just it didn't work for
me that show kind of didn't work I wasn't very
excited by it but I watched a few you can't even
remember the name of it the I can't good musical
choices I like what I liked about it have you seen
the Goosebumps movie with Jack Black no okay so
it's kind of similar and plot sort of okay in
the sense of all these Goosebumps characters are
coming a life and then they have to like outrun
and survive and figure out how to put them back
in the books oh cool it's a neat plot now my one
of my main complaints about that movie is whenever
a a character from Goose Goose mums came up it was
kind of the same bit all the time character shows
up and they got to run away from it and that's
pretty much it character shows up and they got
run away from and what I thought was neat about
this is sure I mean it gets to a point where it's
just like a bombastic cacophony of just shoot the
thing like sure but I still think there was enough
where they made an actual choice to Let's create
a level out of it you know yeah like actually play
it cuz they're not really running in the beginning
a little bit they're playing playing it while
yeah it's like a VR experience but instead of
VR it's you're actually it's a threat you know
so to have like the totally what was the first
one the cic C what was that one the centipede
centipede centipede uh the centipede one like
even with that it was more than just shoot there
was a strategy and the pattern the whole thing
right of course Pac-Man um and then with and then
like Donkey Kong and and when yeah that one was
dope cuz that was a real set that we partially
they built and then also with FFX and I'm like
I think they had them on um like a lift like when
they put you on a lift cuz I'm like there's no way
Michelle manam but there was one where she's
running on that thing and she jumps over the
barrel and I'm like it seems like they had them on
a lift so they could do that and then they place
them back down you can keep running but you just
CGI the thing out and I feel like they did that
with the actual people with the actual actors
which and I don't know but it that's maybe a
reason why it also looks super dope yeah that's
all likely yes um and then uh uh the even like
with the tetris one on the building oh that was
so smart even though it's brief I'm like that's
really inventive of how of how they're doing that
I like how in comedy it starts off where there's a
lot of like uh my God sorry no sleep there's a lot
of uh a lot of there like a wack like a slightly
wacky character and then there's a straight man
right there's a lot of that kind of interaction
and then as the movie gets a little bit later you
kind of get um more wacky characters interacting
each other like I actually really love the way
that scene went down with Josh Gad and the and
the girl when he first encounters her like how
they just commit to the genre of whatever like
weird fantasy this is at the time yeah of how she
she plays it subtle she never speaks yeah and um
I think that actress is named Ashley Benson am I
wrong about that um but yeah I love how she just
never speaks and just the way her she emotes there
or and like even Peter Dinklage was he wasn't that
funny at first no I wish I wish that he had gotten
to do it in his regular accent cuz he would have
been hilarious I feel like he actually might
have been funnier if he did in his own accent
way funnier cuz like Peter is so funny and the
second he to opened up to start to talk I was like
this accent is not going to work and his delivery
and tone and pacing is going to be totally thrown
off by it and I wish that they just would have
made the kid like from London but he still lived
around and because Peter he's Prime Time funny
what he just didn't get a chance with the accent
there was like two or three moments later on like
in the finale I can't remember what but I was like
oh [__] that was hilar I can't remember what
he there was some line he had that he actually
delivered I was like that oh that he was like at
least I'd get a nice tasty Panini out that Pini
line was really well delivered the Pini line was
really funny his reaction to Martha yes yeah oh
even when like Josh Gad was like oh life and like
his reaction to that was really funny so funny
and even in the beginning in the prison I was sort
of listening to that scene being so excited Peter
dingl is in it but then he starts talking I'm
like I don't like any of this the accent seems
way off and more I didn't like it but anyway when
he stopped talking and he they were telling him
about like you can't have an island Camp these
things if you just look at Peter Peter he is the
best at quick subtle reactions that are so funny
like a flint of the eye he'll just like do a thing
with like his eyes and you're like what that was
it's such a brilliant reaction that I just want
to see him on camera always yeah and I you know
I I got to give it up for I this is the kind of
movie where I don't feel like people will would
talk about Michelle Monahan and not that she is
the star performer of this right but she really
kept up with the rest of the cast very well and
they gave her a role that was different than than
again like most of these unless you're Drew Barry
more than most of these like Adam s movies and um
and I liked how she was able to play a character
that at first just seems like divorce wife and
then you find out she's actually this high ranking
official in the government and she she pulls off
the the whole layers of the character well and
she had some there was like a couple of pretty
funny like she that line about the Donkey Kong
thing like the editing and the way she delivered
it uh uh was it was so genuine it was so genuine
and that's what made it hilarious yeah I was I
was really surprised by how much they actually
used her and I thought having them as like a heart
of the of the dynamic of of like the the Romantic
every one of these Adam s movies has a romantic
angle but but I thought like that actually worked
really well here yeah and didn't feel like just
a thing they had to do like cuz I like how came
in they needed her to be in that to help the the
story progress which is what we all want of like
not just in there because like Jane Jane is just
in there to be a wife to the president she is not
needed as a character I mean maybe they just
like he needs a wife but like uh in regards
to the script in like story building in the way
we needed Michelle Monahan's like character and
they did utilize her in it with good intent cuz
I think what most movies would have done is after
he's already like with the military Adam Sandler
then he meets her and then and it's like here we
go Force romance but to actually have them Bond
prior in a completely separate and then get into
their their spat beforehand and then I was like
okay this works much smarter as opposed to what
the most movies will do yeah I agree yeah and it
gives us the build up of also with the sun and how
video game Heavy he is like he's a nerd and an
adult and very you know thrown into that video
game thing but then it proves to be useful all
right so before we end this off I want to show you
what Chris columus has directed cuz he's directed
a lot and I'm sure let me see where's where's okay
he's PR going so fast I'm I'm on the producer
credit speed what's going on here here we go
he's directed a lot and for someon I can call the
adventures and babysitting oh my God that that was
one of my favorite home alone2 Home Alone movies
Mrs daire 9 months so good he did direct the first
two Harry Potter movies yeah uh rent ooh Percy
Jackson i' I've been wanting to react to Percy
Jackson I thought we we going to do it let's do
it you you I haven't seen any of them I haven't
seen the Percy Jacks movies Christmas Chronicles
part two I don't think I've seen so I might have
to watch that cuz he has directed some very good
films that I love that's insane yeah and he like
a high prolific producer as well oh he produces a
lot huh yeah he's produced a [__] ton of movies
um yeah he's a big ass producer but yeah man I I
I really I've got I'm not going to lie I enjoyed
the hell out of that film I I am good times I
was reluctantly step I was just like let's just
choose one of the comedies cuz I just but that
surprisingly uh that that brought me a lot of
Joy I had a really great time with that it makes
me want to say Chris Columbus this is my this is
my note to you I'm an actor put me in your stuff
do it because your stuff is great and I am just
realizing how much great stuff you've directed you
won't ever watch this or hear this but I'm saying
there's might be people that are like hey man I
know Chris Chris is my best friend and then you're
like yo Chris Tara Ericson right and then you're
like get get on it get with it get with it put me
to work in as an actor do it yeah don't anyway
okay that's it that's I you have another movie
to shoot with Aaron I do and I'm pretty sure he's
outside he's outside right now probably end the
video we have to go yeah we love you so much leave
a like leave a comment tell us how cool we are and
ring the bell and we love you so much by all the
t-shirts become a patreon okay bye all right guys
since we have uh only a few days left in the
month we have to make sure that we are getting
everyone taken care of for our super sexies who
get a patron of the day shout out so we're going
to have to do two shout outs in this video and uh
so what two people do we know John just named I
actually got a perfect two I think would go really
nicely together who and that's Maria Hammond okay
and fev Doran fascinating because they're both
get this they're both different you know walks
of life different kinds of people however both
uh bring this generous enthusiastic spirit and
I feel like if Maria was to adopt fev they could
create like the most perfect wholesome you know
uh uh uh the kind of family unit you would want
to move into your neighborhood because you know
they would be taken care of of you you know they
would be bringing you gifts and things they would
be cooking for you but they would also be sharing
in your interests you know what I mean they're two
you know uh enthusiastic passionate people but who
also seem to really want to care for the people
around them you know what I mean and I'm grateful
for those vibes wow you know I was I I I thought
we would just do a one at a time and just say what
we're grateful for about them and then you turned
this into some crazy amalgamation about adoption
and let's do your version now I don't know if we
we could I think we got a roll with this one I
got a yes and it but I wanted to interrupt with
my no but briefly yes before going into the yes
and here um yeah I like I like where your head's
at than Maria's a very tender woman yes with a and
she loves to spoil those that are her children or
on she considers to be like her children yeah
and L is great at expressing his gratitude for
those things so childlike wonder I think that the
two of them together if they were mother and son
there would just be a constant it would be kind
of annoying the amount of appreciation they would
just keep dishing back and forth to each other I
they're also both very passionate so I could see
it getting like really heated and it's all flowers
until they find that one thing they disagree on
yeah they disagree on it then it just gets like
oh ugly business and they probably don't talk
to each other for like 6 day business days and
then eventually eventually they would come back
around again and realize we need to put our petty
squabbles to the side and know what we mad about
yeah and then eventually they would remember
and then ccle continue of gratitude vitriol
just doesn't stop gra a vitrio well damn dude um I
mean I love you both uh one gives us more than the
other uh in terms of physical tangible gifts we
can actually hold on camera and put on the set yes
so you know there's that meaning fed if you want
more gratitude from us yeah spend more of your
hard-earned dollars cuz that's the key to my heart
that's my love language gifts yes um I don't I
don't like the other love language I think they'll
waste of everyone's time going to replace all the
the links on the Channel Bio description with just
your wish list please please get more of those
Nifty cabinets over there please man got some new
cabinets in the studio was so excited no it's not
about that FL you give what you can which is not
enough no you give what you can you got to always
have something to strive for you know what I mean
you know you always you've always been extremely
generous with us via your patreon dollars but also
with your time and your energy your thoughts you
contribute to like every single live stream
that we do and Maria before you know it I'm
I'm expecting to hear some loud tow truck outside
called what is being hauled and then I'm going to
hear like oh damn she's just dropped off a cruise
ship right into our driveway cuz that's the kind
that's that's the I mean let's face it after
everything you've given us Maria that's just the
next step is a cruise ship a giant boing vessel
a giant boat just right outside our door can you
imagine how cool a reject Nation yacht could be
I know and we react live on the yacht yeah the
camera would never stay still oh yeah it' be very
nausey in cuz will be still but the background
will always be moving yeah cick reaction but all
jokes aside uh you both are incredibly generous
and both heartwarming souls in every regard
it's a good pair John good job thanks would
make it weird you made it weird you all right
talk to you soon thanks for being here [Music]